[Music]
this morning we are celebrating a
cultural phenomenon unlike any other it
has been 50 years since soul train first
crossed the tracks of our minds the show
premiered back in 1971 as a showcase for
black musical talent and influenced
everything from dance to dress and even
ad spending the broadcast which ran for
35 seasons remains one of the longest
running syndicated shows in american
history and continues to inspire
generations of artists across genres
i joined music and culture journalist
and author nelson george at rough trade
records in new york city to discuss how
soul train came to be and its enduring
legacy
[Music]
it's been half a century since soul
train rolled onto the scene and into the
history books here's your host don
cornelius chicago dj don cornelius
created the show to highlight black
artists largely ignored by the
mainstream charts gotta remember there
is no national black shows showcasing
black music you could have you know the
supremes on that sullivan but that's a
one shot journalist and filmmaker nelson
george is author of soul train the
hippest trip in america don's i did was
kids and big name acts just black music
the show was an instant hit in chicago
and relocated to los angeles to be
broadcast nationally soul train show
number 154 but cornelius was an unknown
in hollywood the biggest challenge he
had without the booking talent who is
this guy he's another black dj from the
midwest unable to land big name acts on
the west coast soul train turned to
local tower a move that would give the
show its signature when you think of
soul train we know it's black music
but the stars are the show of the
dancers originally known as the soul
train gang the dancers changed the way
america learned to move before then
dance traveled almost word of mouth what
soul train did was take the kind of an
anecdotal way that black dance traveled
and put it on a national thing so things
like pop popping locking all these
different dance styles they go from
soul train into every school yard in
america in one day when the jackson five
appeared and did dancing machine
and michael got up there
and did the robot
the next day
every kid is out there like oh yeah yeah
do the robot but when did
the musicians all of a sudden realize
you got to be on soul train well i think
one of the big gets was james brown
[Music]
because james brown was the guy and once
brown said it was okay it helped open up
the floodgates how about a gang from
miss aretha franklin stevie wonder the
moments fully guaranteed
[Music]
[Applause]
hey soul train was the national
vehicle for black music from 1971
untouched into the 90s
but more than just a music dance variety
show soul train depicted black life like
never before i always say that black joy
was the weapon the civil rights movement
didn't know it had you're not seeing
them marching and protesting you're
seeing the fun part of black culture so
this was a window in the black culture
that had never been ever on american tv
[Music]
and decades later soul train is still
celebrating the best in seoul and r b
with the b-e-t soul train awards
[Music]
we caught up with grammy-nominated
singer-songwriter leon bridges during
rehearsals for the award show at the
world famous apollo theater in harlem
growing up my family was super religious
but they made an exception
for
soul music my father you know he he put
me on to the og soul train you know and
so curtis mayfield
[Music]
he created the blueprint of what r b
guitar is you know fast forward to when
you know i picked up a guitar from the
first time i tried to
just kind of channel that energy this
year's awards are celebrating soul
train's 50th anniversary and the apollo
is the perfect backdrop says award show
executive producer connie orlando all
artists were like we got to do that
stage we have to do the apollo stage we
have to do the soul train stage because
when you went there it was home some of
the greatest
soul artists and r b artists have graced
that stage and so i feel like there's a
little bit of you know lingering magic
everybody
and soul trains magic born out of an
idea that music and moves of black
culture should be celebrated and chanted
everyone into understanding that this is
america i would say that don built a
platform people say solo train line
everyone gets happy it's just america
it's just americana
it's part of the culture
i'm don cornelius and as always in
parting we wish you love
peace
and soul
and like don used to say if you didn't
get it it can't be got
that is soul training i tell you my
girlfriends being in la
my friends in high school would go down
stand in line to try and get
into the soul train taping and there was
only one who did angelique [ __ ] into the
division she made it in
legend dance like no other it wasn't
just black artists who performed
david bowie played on soul train that
was huge i mean elton john was one of
the biggest stars in the world still is
and for him to play soul train it was
huge it was a huge moment and we were
all talking about it all all morning as
we've been saying i remember it coming
on tv and you remember that moment and
seeing the train 11 a.m right 11 87 am
that's what i remember would come on and
i that was me my uncle and my aunt they
were like teenagers and we all went out
the next day everybody was like
your robot was good what wedding doesn't
have a soul train line right everywhere
every wedding everybody gets happy all
right so the 2021 so
training a little higher pitch
dana bringing it way better than not
good that's at 8 pm eastern and pacific
on b-e-t of course the division of icon
cbs and head to cbsmornings.com and our
social media feed for an extended
behind-the-scenes look i joined the
apollo's executive producer camila
forbes to discuss the theater's history
and continuing cultural impact yeah
she's a good one you know her